I have no idea when did it start.
Who am I?
Why am I here?
I was diagnosed with tuberculosis meningitis, which complicated into hydrocephalus.
And then, that's when I started forgetting things.
I just remember waking up with no memory.
I couldn't even recognize my own reflection.
I had to get used to this idea that this is how I look.
Absolutely nothing made sense.
I had no idea what relationships meant,...
...that you are my father, that she was my mother, this was my brother.
I did not speak to anybody because I didn't recognize them,...
...and I didn't know what to say.
I lost 27 years of experiences.
It's the past that makes you who you are, right?
So, who am I?
When I was well enough to use and work on a computer,...
...I started browsing through my history list,....
...and there was this website called Facebook on it.
And then it suggested that these are the people you may know,...
...and that's how it started.
Memories : They're not lost; they're there somewhere.
If I can recognize one thing, I can identify the pieces of the puzzle.
Imagine if that too aren't there.
How would I feel or connect with anything?
That's how I've been building my whole life.